I'm not a good person.
Well, whatever.
You're... fine.
I killed a kid.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
It's not a unique insight
that sometimes
when you say
the unsayable thing,
you realize
it wasn't that unsayable.
It sounds like the story
of a hero to me.
I would've been straight
out of there.
Serious. I would've been
out of that water
like a tabby cat out of a bath.
(CHUCKLES) Don't, man.
Jokes often bring a new way
of looking at things.
And it seemed true
and right that quite quickly,
someone like Roman
starts making jokes
and there's something terrible
about that,
but there's something
liberating as well.
I guess I'm just trying
to say, like,
who's the real victim here?
I waited three-quarters
of an hour for a gin and tonic.
(CHUCKLES, SNIFFLES)
JESSE ARMSTRONG:
Kendall sees that
it's not something
that's the end,
some things will continue,
including a relationship
and even love from his siblings.
So, we go see him
and we tell him
we just won't have it, right?
JESSE ARMSTRONG: Roman
has the most difficult decision
because his position
through the season has changed,
and the way he feels
valued by his dad has changed.
Kendall's already declared
as an antagonist,
Shiv finds that's how she feels
when the prospect
of losing the company arises.
You think Dad is protecting you?
Hmm?
No, we let Mattson take control,
that is Dad slamming the door.
It means that he doesn't
ever think we will,
can, or should take over.
Time to rip off the band-aid.
There's always been
the feeling of,
"What if we could all go in
and fire the water pistol
together?
If we could all say
the same thing at once,
what would happen?"
Full coup.
It's an exhilarating power,
and it's quite intoxicating.
We can fight it out.
It'll be fun.
That will be fun. (CHUCKLES)
♪ ("SUCCESSION" THEME
PLAYS SOFTLY) ♪
MARK MYLOD: I look at the arc
of this season,
from the chaos at the end
of episode two.
Fuck you, Plastic Jesus.
You're a fucking twat.
Save the planet, Ken.
You're a fucking prick.
And there we are,
episode nine,
and the siblings,
however damaged,
found their way back together
for the first time, really,
since their teenage years,
I think.
LOGAN ROY: Send them in!
Come in, come in, come in.
MARK: I came into the scene
really anxious
to find our way through
these pivotal moments
of the first problem for me,
where Roman is having
to face the dragon,
to face his father.
Can you take him out,
Romulus?
And to stand up to his father,
which of course,
he palpably failed to do
if we look back
at season one, episode six.
You better be smelling
your fucking armpit, Romulus.
There's a question about why,
when in the first season,
he wasn't able to raise
his hand,
and why is he able to now?
Roman... I thought we had
this figured out.
Yeah, it just might be better,
you know, if we all hear.
Some people would see growth.
I'm on the fence
about human beings,
and people certainly change
what they do,
but in my view,
people's essential selves
don't change.
In a way, that's what makes
drama and choices interesting.
I've got you.
Come on, let's discuss.
So, I would say
that the circumstances
around Roman have changed.
This is an opportunity, son.
He feels this weight
of support
that makes it possible
for him to be a full sibling.
You can trust me.
You can't trust him.
JESSE: It's a superpower
that Logan has,
to be able to lie
to people's faces,
and then if people have
the power to make him
come good on those promises,
then he will.
And if they don't,
then they're in a new situation,
and there'll have to be
a new accommodation found.
We can stop you.
You're playing
toy fucking soldiers!
I have you beat!
Do you want a deal
with the devil?
JESSE: The implication
is that Tom is the one
who blew the whistle
on the kids
and enabled Logan
to secure the deal,
which they could've
stymied.
Caroline, you're on!
JESSE: Tom's been on his way
to making
this kind of choice
for a long time unconsciously.
(WHISPERS) Who the fuck
told him?
JESSE: Since Shiv's admission
on their wedding night
that she had
had an affair,
and since a few nights
before that,
when she said
that she doesn't love him.
I think he does love her
quite passionately,
and she, after her own fashion,
loves him.
But there are a lot
of caveats for both of them.
If you're being generous
to them,
then their relationship
is very complicated.
We're gonna force him out.
And where do I fit in, Shiv?
Well, high up, Tom,
I don't know.
MARK: He's a realist
and a romantic,
one of the incredible,
kind of beautiful complications
about Tom.
So, it was kind of inevitable,
at some point,
that he would put self
before her.
JESSE: Other people
who are in the family
will always be a Roy,
will always be
in the newspapers,
but Tom maybe
has a certain cold calculation
to make
about what he needs to give if
he's gonna stay in that world.
Hey.
For a long time,
I couldn't find the ending.
And then, we did a take
where we gave Sarah's character
time to process that moment.
You should've trusted me.
MARK: And when Tom walked over
and said, "You okay?"
You okay?
Despite that absolutely
extraordinary betrayal,
she put a game face on
and said, "Yep."
Yeah.
MARK: And because
it was such a perfect
kind of Succession moment,
that she would still
somehow find the strength
to put that Teflon coat on
and be in denial of that pain
was so powerful to me
that I knew we had
the end of the season.